it's my pleasure
again to be hosting dan binet so dan it
heads the applied cryptography group and
co-directs the computer security lab
here at stanford
his research focuses on applications of
cryptography to computer security
in addition to being a a researcher he
is also an innovative educator even
before
kovic kind of pushed all of us online he
had been doing a lot online and putting
a lot of
making a lot of materials free out there
so one thing he does is he's the
co-director of stanford's
advanced cyber security professional
program which i'll talk a little bit
more
about at the end of the webinar as well
as our online cyber security graduate
program he is also has a mooc on
coursera on cryptography
and he has co-written a free online
textbook on applied cryptography that
you can find on his website i think the
latest
edition is from january 2020 but it's
been there since 2008.
so again it's my pleasure to host dan
today who's going to be talking about
the
um the privacy and security machine
learning models
and with that i'm going to hand it over
to him so let's get started
so welcome everyone i'm excited to be
talking about
uh about this the machine learning and
security and privacy of in particular of
machine learning
uh so this will be kind of an overview
talk about some of the latest research
in this uh in this area but it's mostly
meant to be kind of a high over intro
high level introduction and i'll give
some more
materials for people who want to um
learn more about this topic at the end
of the
end of the webinar okay so with that
let's get started and i'm actually
really looking forward to your questions
so please type your questions and i'll
come back to them at the end of the talk
and feel free to ask questions about
anything anything in security i know
this topic we're primarily going to be
talking about
security or machine learning this in
this webinar but feel free to ask
anything
in uh in computer security okay so
let's get started so machine learning is
as you know
is amazing in that it's able to achieve
super human
performance on many many different tasks
now
um however what i want to show you in
this in the next couple of minutes
is basically that even though machine
learning works really well
on sort of random examples out there in
the real world it turns out
under under adversarial examples
specifically in adversarial environments
it tends to have some problems yeah and
that's what i want to talk about but
before we get to that
i just want to quickly make sure we're
all on the same page so let me talk a
little bit about
what the machine learning pipeline looks
like specifically i'll specifically talk
about what's called supervised learning
so imagine we want to train some cars to
to self-drive
yeah so what we do is basically we go
through a data collection phase where we
collect
data from all of all the cars out there
yeah so everybody
sends data let's say we want to train
them to recognize road signs
so everybody collects label data you can
see that you know this car
sent that this is a yield sign and
labeled as a yield this car said it's a
stop sign labeled as a stop
generally these things are denoted as x
is the example
and y is the label so we get many
examples and many corresponding labels
and we're trying to learn to build a
classifier that classifies road signs
so we talk we take all the examples we
collected all the labels
labeled examples we collected and we
pushed them through
um through a machine learning model a
machine learning algorithm
and that's called the training phase
right so what the machine learning
algorithm does is it produces what we
call
model parameters which are typically
denoted by theta
and those model parameters basically are
the
uh parameters that drive the neural net
yeah so what is the neural net
a neural net basically is a graph as you
can see in the picture here
and the model parameters basically are
the weights on the edges
in this in this graph okay so we have
these model parameters that the training
algorithm
produced and then the next thing we do
is we send the model parameters over
back to all the cars and now the cars
can
uh basically use this new model that we
just trained to recognize road signs
what's really kind of amazing about this
is it's very different from how humans
learn
right so humans basically each one of us
has to run has to collect data
examples on our own and then we run the
training algorithm in our own minds
and then we use the results of the
training to kind of do the tasks we need
to do
whereas in machine learning what's
interesting is if one car finds an
example that's not classified correctly
you know a road sign that's not
classified correctly
it sends it back to the home base in the
home base
they rerun the training algorithm and
then all the cars
get better as a result yeah so it's kind
of a very different process
from what humans go through so once
we've sent the model to all the cars
we have the inference step where
basically now a car say
sees a particular a particular road sign
it uses the model
theta that was sent to it and then it
classifies basically saying this is a
yield sign with very high probability
and it's a stop sign with very low
probability so then the car says oh i'm
probably seeing the yield sign
okay so this is how basically machine
learning is supposed to work
however as we'll see in just a minute uh
there are some
possibilities for attacks okay so in all
of this pipeline you know there are
these three steps data collection
training and inference it turns out in
all three steps of this pipeline
there are opportunities for attack so
let's see how
how this would work um okay so the first
example i want to go through very
quickly
is a fantastic example of an attack
during uh during training this is an
example to do to one of my colleagues
priscilla yang and the students and it
really kind of drives the point on
how reliable we are on on valid training
data
so what they did is they basically they
looked at they were trying to build a
classifier to classify images of cats of
dogs versus fish
okay so the two classes were dogs and
fish
so they had like 6 000 images in their
data sets and what they did is they took
just
one image one of the six thousand
labeled images
and they added very carefully uh chosen
noise to it you see the noise will scale
down
so really the resulting image looks like
the original image
except a little bit of low volume noise
was added to it
and you notice this picture has a dog
and a fish in it
what they did is they labeled this image
as a fish
okay so they really poisoned just one
entry
in the entire training set and as a
result when you train an algorithm now
using this poisoned
data set so six thousand images only one
of them was poisoned
it turns out the model actually produces
an incorrect
the training algorithm produces an
incorrect model yeah so for example
if you show the new model these pictures
that are clearly pictures of dogs
the old model the original model without
the poison data set
you can see says this is a dog with 97
98 98
probability however once you poison one
element in the training set all of a
sudden
now the model becomes confident this is
a fish
with 97 93 and 87 probability
okay so i think this is a pretty strong
statement
about the training data that if an
attacker can look at your training data
and basically corrupt just one entry say
just
one car sends one corrupt entry that
actually is enough
to completely uh lead the training
algorithm awry
and as a result the resulting model is
um
just makes incorrect results incorrect
conclusions so again keep that in mind
when you run when you collect training
data you have to make sure
the training data comes from trusted
sources okay the more interesting
attacks i want to talk about are attacks
during inference
yeah so after we've trained the model
and now we show it a bunch of examples
um the question is how well does it
classify the examples we show it
and so here there's a very large field
of
what's called adversarial machine
learning or particularly it's called
adversarial examples
this was created back in 2013 2014
and it's an amazing set of set of
results that basically says the
following thing
you can train a model to recognize cats
okay so
um you can give it a picture of a cat
and the model
says very high confidence this is a cat
the amazing thing is you can now take
this image of a cat
and add a little bit of noise to it yeah
so again this is carefully chosen noise
i'll explain how we choose it
in just a minute and then you tamper it
down yeah you multiply it by a very
small number
so the actual perturbation to the image
is a very very small perturbation
we just changed you know the pixel
values by a very small amount you can
see that when you um
look at the final image to a human
there's no difference this image looks
exactly like the original image
but it's been perturbed a little bit the
amazing thing is when you when you give
the model this perturbed image
all of a sudden the model says i am
completely confident this is guacamole
yeah not a cat it's something completely
different so how does this work
how do how do we generate these
adversarial examples so i should say
this is what's called
an adversarial example you give me a
model i give an i
i construct an example that the model
gets completely wrong
so how do we do this well here you have
like a three-dimensional terrain
of different images so every pixel here
corresponds to one image
and the height of the terrain
corresponds to how confident the model
is
that the given image is a cat so you can
see the gray area
corresponds to the gray to the cat zone
everything in the gray area
would be considered considered a cat
everything in the
i don't know what this is this blue area
is
would be considered guacamole okay so um
these two concept classes
you notice they kind of intro they have
a close boundary
uh between them and it turns out there's
one direction one specific direction
that if you go down then it turns out
with very few changes you have to make a
very small step
very small perturbation that takes you
into the guacamole step you notice if
you walk in a random direction
so you go right or left you're going to
stay in the cap
area direction yeah so actually just
going in around just adding a random
perturbation
is not going to confuse the model at all
but if you take a perturbation that's
just in the right direction that pushes
the model
quickly into the guacamole area then the
model gets confused
okay then it thinks that this this cat
this perturbed cat
is guacamole yeah so this is how this
works and the way this the algorithm
for doing this is called fgsm fast
gradient sine method
which basically looks for the steepest
descent
in this terrain and then it just makes a
few steps in the
gradient direction and that ensures that
the model that the category is going to
change
with very small perturbations okay so
that's the idea
of adversarial examples one thing that i
wanted to point out
is that in fact it turns out uh there
are many directions
that you can go in that would introduce
adversarial examples
here in the previous slide i said you
walk in the gradient direction that's
one direction
that would cause an adversarial example
to appear but it turns out
we did an experiment a few years ago to
show that for example for this for these
models these three models
v3 v3 adds and and another variant to v3
these are models for identifying images
it turns out something like 60
of the images in the data set have um
like 20 adversarial directions
yeah so if you think about an image an
image is um
uh you know a point in a very high
dimensional space
right an image has thousands if not
millions of pixels in it so we're in
in the dimension that we're in could be
in the hundreds of thousands every pixel
corresponds to one dimension
and yet uh there are the gradient gives
you one direction to get adversarial
examples but it turns out many images
actually have many directions that will
give you adversarial examples
all right so uh fgsm is one way to do it
but in fact there are other ways to do
it to do it as well
it turns out now these adversarial
examples basically affect
everything yeah literally every model
that's been trained
is vulnerable to adversarial examples so
let me just give you a few examples
so one classic one is a model that's
trained to recognize faces
yeah so you you give it uh let's say 50
faces
you train it to recognize one of 50
faces and then it turns out if you want
to
confuse it um there was this really
beautiful experiment
in 2016 that showed that you can print
3d glasses
these are physical 3d glasses that you
can put on your face and when you put
those glasses
on your face the model all of a sudden
thinks that you're brad pitt if it's
been trained to recognize bradfit
yeah so just by printing 3d glasses and
putting them
on on your face you can confuse the
model into thinking that you're in a
class that you're not
actually actually in and of course the
reason that works
is because the model picked up on some
categories around the eyes and some
features
around the eyes and these glasses
basically mirror the features that the
model is actually looking for
another example famous example is uh
road signs yeah so it turns out you can
take a stop sign
uh train a model to recognize stop signs
recognize speed speed limit speed limit
signs
you can put a few stickers on the stop
sign and all of a sudden again to us
this still looks like a stop sign
but all of a sudden the model says oh
this is a 40 40 miles per hour speed
limit sign
it's not a stop sign so if a car was
using this the car would not stop
even though it's supposed to yeah and
the third example i'll give is in the
audio domain again a very famous example
uh you know we all have these phones
where you say hey siri and the phone
wakes up and executes our commands
well what they showed is that you can
actually create white noise this
literally just sounds like white noise
to the human ear but it's very carefully
crafted white noise
that the model interprets this is as the
user saying hey siri
open evil.com so you might be holding
your phone in some environment all of a
sudden this white noise plays in the
background
and your your phone ends up going to
email.com as a result
to you it just sounds like white noise
so you have no idea that your phone is
under attack
yeah so these are all examples of these
are all adversarial examples
where the model is trained to do one
thing but we can give it a carefully
crafted
malicious example and the model all of a
sudden gets confused
so why is this happening well here i
just i'll just say this very briefly
i'll just tell you that
the solid line here represents the true
concept we're trying to learn
like you know stop signs and the dashed
line represents what the model
actually learns right and those two
things are different the model
learns sort of an approximation of the
cr of the true concept
and if you look to the far left you'll
see that there is an x
that if you perturb it just by a little
bit you move it to a point where the
model
actually it's outside of the dashed
lines so the model will classify
differently
but in reality it still is a stop sign
because it's still inside of the solid
line
yeah so you can see the x on the far
left i don't have a pointer so i can't
quite show this to you
but if you just look at the x on the far
left you can see that a very small
perturbation changes moves it out of the
model boundary
but leaves it inside of the true
boundary and that's why these
perturbation examples
uh other sort of examples exist
basically in high dimensional space
there is always a small perturbation
that moves you from one complex concept
class
to another concept class okay so uh
why do these adversarial examples matter
well they matter for a lot of reasons
first of all
it's kind of interesting to learn to
understand basically how does the model
actually work
right they help us understand what was
actually learned and they also help us
understand
um you know uh you know what did these
models like we said like what do they do
like why did they generalize
for security these are really important
right so for security it's really kind
of important to understand
you know how likely is my machine
learning model that i just trained
how likely is it to fail under attack
right if somebody gives it a bad example
uh adversarial example
how likely is it to actually
miscategorize the results that's what
we'd like to understand
now this area like i said this this was
um
first these kind of attacks first came
out in 2014
so what this area is like seven years
old now and since then there have been
thousands of papers written on more
attacks
and many many attempts at defending
against these attacks so many many
defensive techniques have been have been
tried
unfortunately many of these proposed
defenses have actually been broken and
there's actually sort of a cat and mouse
game
where somebody writes a defense and
somebody then implements um
an attack yeah so that uh it's been
quite challenging
to come out with come up with uh robust
defenses
it turns out some of the defenses that
we have work and you know these are some
examples of defenses
that um that do a decent job however
it's important to understand
that these defenses basically only
defend against
one type of perturbation for example you
might only want to
defend against perturbations that have
what's called low
l2 norm yeah so that you can modify all
the pixels
but only by a small amount however there
could be other types of perturbations
where maybe you can modify
a small number of pixels but those small
pixels you can modify quite a lot
that corresponds to putting sticker on a
stop sign where um
you're modifying a small number of
pixels but those you're
modifying quite a bit yeah that's
sometimes called a hamming perturbation
maybe an l0 perturbation and so it turns
out that
these methods that do work are they work
very well
for the set of perturbations they were
trained to defend against
but they don't work very well once you
give them a new type of perturbation
yeah they again
start to be vulnerable to adversarial
examples that's what happens
so yeah so that's what that's kind of a
result it says that they're they're
very good at defending against the
chosen set but
that's the result on the left but
they're not very good at defending
against
other types of perturbations what's
weird is something we showed a couple
again in 2019 that if you try to train a
model to be robust to
multiple types of perturbations let's
say both l2 norm
low l2 norm and low hemming weight norm
uh it turns out
you the models you end up with actually
are not as robust as you'd like
yeah so it's kind of interesting that uh
training to secure to be robust to
multiple
perturbations is not as as good as uh
training
against a narrower set of perturbations
yeah so that's kind of the state of the
art um
unfortunately what this means is as of
today
we still don't have a complete defense
against these adversarial examples yeah
so
this is um a pretty interesting thing to
remember so any of you who actually use
machine learning model in the machine
learning models in the real world
basically whenever someone comes to you
and say that you're using
ml for for certain tasks you should
always ask them
what happens if somebody presents an
adversarial example to you yeah so for
example
if you use an ml model to classify spam
email
or to classify security events or maybe
even in medical conditions right or
maybe
um there's a reason to behave
adversarially
that you should always keep in the back
of your mind this question of
what happens if somebody presents an
adversarial example and the model
actually misclassifies yeah so if you're
trying if you're training a car to
recognize road signs you have to ask
yourself
well what happens if my if my model
actually encounters
an adversarial example and misclassifies
the road sign
yeah so that's kind of a very important
lesson to take away from this line of
research
that you always always always have to
have adversarial examples in your mind
when you try to deploy machine learning
algorithms in the real world
it turns out so you should ask yourself
you know is it possible to have
adversary to have completely robust
adversarial
models sorry completely robust machine
learning models well
you know humans are pretty good we're
pretty robust you can kind of show us
all sorts of examples all sorts of
perturbed images and you know we would
just ignore the perturbations but it
turns out that even we are not perfect
yeah this is there are a lot of optical
illusions
here's a famous optical illusion where
if i show you
show you these two shapes and i ask you
which one is bigger
you would say oh clearly shape b is
bigger at least most of us will say play
that shape b is bigger but it turns out
if you just look at it stare at a little
bit longer you realize these two shapes
are identical in fact if you look at
where these edges are
uh the right side edges you'll see that
they're exactly
one underneath the other so these two
shapes are actually identical but
somehow our um
optical but somehow our vision system
makes this mistake so it's quite
possible
that you know maybe they're even we
think of ourselves as robust but
clearly we're not robust either so maybe
there is no perfectly robust
ml model and we'll never have something
that's not going to be vulnerable
to adversarial examples yeah by the way
what's interesting
about this is also that all of us were
trained
on different uh examples and all of us
used our own built-in
uh training algorithm right so you know
there are
however many people on the planet all of
us trained our visual system
uh using examples that we saw when we
were growing up
and yet these this example fools all of
us or
you know a large fraction of us yeah and
so what this what this illustrates is a
really interesting example called of a
phenomena called
transferability where in fact if you
train one model
in one way on one data set and you build
adversarial examples against that model
it turns out those adversarial examples
will also fool other models that were
trained on independent data sets
in different ways so even in machine
learning there is transferability where
one or an adversarial example against
one model
can confuse a model that was trained
completely independently
just like this confuses me this image
confuses me
uh but it also confuses you even both of
even though both of us were trained
on completely independent uh labeled
examples
okay so um the last example i want to
show you in terms of
inference attacks is uh isn't is is a
kind of work we did a few elections with
last year or so
uh on an area where you would think ml
would be useful but it turns out it's
actually
quite vulnerable to adversarial examples
so let me tell you the story because
it's kind of a cute story
um so this is basically an example where
you'd like to use machine learning to
block ads
yeah so you have a web page the web page
uh displays ads like you go to the new
york times and the new york times
displays
displays ads to you and the user some
users would like to actually block those
ads so they can just read the content
without seeing the ads
so there's this perpetual war between ad
blockers
like adblock plus which you can install
on your browser to block ads
and the publishers like the new york
times right the new york times wants the
ads to be shown on the screen
and the ad blocker wants the ads to be
taken off the screen so that the user
wouldn't won't see them
so there's this war between the ad
blockers and
the publishers and so what what the
publishers do is they make their page
very complicated yeah so the html in the
page is very complicated to parse so it
becomes very difficult for the eye
blocker
to tell what's just by looking at the
code it's very difficult to tell
to tell what's an ad and what's not an
ad so a few years ago
there was this idea called perceptual ad
blocking
where it was supposed to be kind of the
end-all at the ultimate ad blocker
so what it would do is it would actually
render the page as the page is supposed
to be rendered
and then it would actually just look at
the pixels and the idea was to train a
machine learning model
to recognize ads on the page right
humans can recognize
ads on the page pretty well so let's
train a machine learning model to
recognize
ads on the page and then once we from
the pixel
pixels once we recognize which pixels
corresponds to ads
we can just block those pixels yeah so
perceptual ad blocking
is supposed to be this ultimate way to
prevent ads from showing
because the machine learning model will
recognize the ads
and then just block them okay so this is
something adblock plus was actually
considering deploying this in a system
called sentinel
however it turns out this is like the
hardest setting for machine learning
right first of all the model is
completely public
right every browser contains a copy of
the model because
well it needs to decide what's an ad and
what's not an ad the classification task
has to be really fast right the page
loads
and then immediately the model has to
say what's an ad and what's not an ad
you can't think for 30 minutes
before you decide what to block and what
not to block and then the way the
trinity data was collected
was basically by having um adblock plus
uh or rather ad blockers out there in
the wild
send examples of pages with ads and then
you would train
based on those um those examples yeah so
in some sense this is the hardest model
the model is public classification has
to be fast
and the training data uh can be polluted
it's a very hard
setting for machine learning and as a
result it's not too surprising that
there are
attacks on this so this is joint work
with uh my
student florian tremere um dupre rusac
uh
and uh pellegrino and um what
uh what uh this project did is basically
um you know we kind of trained a machine
learning model to recognize ads so you
can see here
on the left you can see a page with a
bunch of ads in it and you can see the
model actually does a pretty good job of
actually picking up
what the ads are yes it is the page
scrolls you can see it it actually
recognizes what's an ad and what's not
an ad
however if you want to defeat this all
you have to do is sort of
add a little bit of adversarial noise
what's the adversarial noise
it's basically going to be a transparent
background
that overlays on top of the web page so
all the new york times
has to do is add this sort of
transparent background
that modifies the page just a little bit
and so you can see this image on the
this video on the right here there's
this transparent background to the user
this is basically invisible but it just
adds a few
you know just modifies the pixel in the
pixels on the page
just a little bit and as a result the
model no longer recognizes the ads you
see none of the ads are now flagged
and as basically that all the ads will
be displayed and that the model doesn't
actually
see them so again it's an example
showing that adversarial examples can
defeat
uh very quite easily defeat adblock it
can defeat a model that is trained to
recognize
ads so you can say well wait a minute
recognizing ads is pretty easy
every ad is required to be to be labeled
by the
by a certain logo saying that it's an ad
like something called the ad choices
logo
right so the ad is supposed to be marked
as an ad so why can't we train a model
to just recognize the ad choices logo
and then from that we can deduce that
it's an ad yeah and then the ad blocker
would block that ad
well it turns out you can actually even
fool that right so you can kind of build
versions of the ad choices logo that
look like the add choices logo to a
human
but the model would not recognize as
would not recognize it as the ad choices
yes so again
it would miss a lot of ads because it
doesn't recognize this this logo that
was built adversarially
again that's a way to over to um to uh
basically evade
this ad blocking machine learning model
and finally the most interesting thing
is not only can you get ads to show you
can actually confuse the model
into blocking the wrong thing so this is
a pretty cute example
so imagine we have like a social network
where
multiple people can load images onto the
same page
it turns out so we have tom here at the
top loaded an image
it turns out uh jerry on the bottom can
actually
upload here let me show you again he can
upload a malicious image
and what that image does is it basically
confuses the segmentation mechanism of
the
ad recognition model yeah so the model
as a result
now thinks that not only is jerry not an
ad
the model gets confused into thinking
that tom is an ad
and as a result it goes ahead and blocks
somebody else's content
yeah so just to make sure this is clear
the mod what happened is the adversarial
example
sort of confused the the the um
you know the fragmentation mechanism in
the machine learning model yeah so it
doesn't recognize
the borders of the ads and as a result
it thinks
that somebody else's content actually is
part of the ad
and goes ahead and blocks it yeah so not
only
can you get your own ads to show you can
actually block other content on the page
so that was kind of a problem and as a
result these methods actually
have not actually been deployed all
right so i think i told you enough about
adversarial examples let's move on to
other to another topic i just want to
make sure you understand
that adversarial examples are kind of a
risk to machine learning models and you
always always
always have to think about them when you
try to deploy a model in the real world
okay so the next thing i want to talk
about is actually how do we
protect data that's being fed into the
model
okay so here's the situation that that i
want to discuss
which is basically a settings where
you the user have a lot of data that
you'd like to classify
yeah maybe you have tens of thousands of
images that you
want to classify using a machine
learning model so typically what you
would do is you would move the model to
the you would
store the model in the cloud the cloud
as you can see has a
rack racks and racks of gpus these
things here on the right
are our gpus that are really fast and
good
at running uh machine learning models
and so you can send your hundred
thousand images to the cloud the cloud
will use its specialized hardware to
classify those images
and send the result back results back to
you is well what if you don't trust the
cloud
yeah suppose the cloud is adversarial
and you actually don't want to send your
private pictures
uh to the cloud what do you do then well
so there are a couple of things we might
ask for right we want to make f first of
all we want to make sure
that the cloud has integrity in other
words the cloud
provides um correctly runs the machine
learning model and provides us with the
right results another thing we might
want is privacy where the cloud
can't actually look at the data and the
third thing we might want is to
keep the model private um so that the
cloud doesn't even learn how our model
works
all right so those are kind of natural
things we might ask
uh the cloud to do so here's a very
natural way to do it
and that's using basically what are
called hardware enclaves yeah so
hardware enclaves are again things
that all of you should know about yeah
so this is basically
a way to dedicate a process
actually dedicate a processor
so some some specialized hardware or
even there are enclaves available
on certain standard processors so
examples of enclaves are things called
intel sgx
risc-5 has an enclave design called
keystone
arm has an enclave design so this is
basically a part
of the processor that can hold secret
data
and even an administrator of that
processor can't get the data out
yeah so the way to think about enclaves
is basically
you hold the processor in your hands the
processor is working yeah think of a
motherboard like a
you know a server uh motherboard that
you hold in your hands
it's executing a certain task and yet
there is nothing you can do
to extract secret data from the enclave
yeah so the enclave
in some sense some sense is protecting
data inside
of it from the owner of the machine that
that owns that that server okay so
that's what
that's what a hardware enclave does and
so the idea would be that we will
encrypt
all of our data that we're going to send
to the cloud so all this
x input would get encrypted under a
public key
where the secret key lives inside of a
cloud
enclave we would then send all this
encrypted data to the cloud
so now the cloud administrator doesn't
see any of it it's all encrypted
but when we load it into the enclave the
enclave has a decryption key
it can go ahead and decrypt the data run
the machine learning model
get the result and send the result back
to us while deleting
the uh the decrypted data so the the
point is that the model and the
decrypted data
only live inside of the hardware enclave
nobody else
can see that data because the hardware
enclave protects it
and as a result the cloud administrator
even if it's malicious
it can't extract the data from the
enclave of course this depends on the
security of the enclave if somehow the
uh the cloud administrator um is able to
tamper with the enclave and extract
values from it
then all bets are off but if we have an
enclave and we assume that it's too
expensive to actually break into the
enclave
then this is actually a pretty
interesting way to protect data that you
send to the cloud yeah and there are
actually a couple of companies
that are deploying this approach to uh
protecting data
okay so this is one way to run privately
uh in the cloud so that the cloud learns
enough nothing about our data however
there's a problem
the problem is that the cloud invested a
lot of money in building
in buying all these gpus the gpus
themselves
don't have enclaves on them yeah gpus
are general purpose
processors yeah and so the gpus are
actually just designed to do
some things very fast they don't have
enclaves on them
as a result with this architecture your
gpus are basically completely idle
everything has to be done on the general
purpose cpu which is
much much much slower so the question is
what to do
and so we designed a system called
slalom that actually allows the hardware
enclave
to interact with the gpus so it's a
multi-round protocol effectively
it's like one round for every layer of
the neural net
yeah so you interact between the general
purpose cpu which has the enclave
and the gpus which has no enclave
effectively everything that gets sent to
the gpu
is encrypted and everything that comes
back from the gpu is verified to be
correct
by the hardware enclave okay so this
ping pong happens back and forth
uh even if you break in into the gpus
and look at everything that's on them
you learn nothing and you can't corrupt
the results because it's all being
checked
by the general purpose cpu okay so that
comes back to the
to the hardware enclave and then the
hardware enclave does its job and sends
the results back to
uh to the client all right so that's how
this works
that's how that's how slalom works it's
basically a way to use gpus in the cloud
even if you want to protect your data
using a hardware enclave
and the amazing thing is that this
actually does achieve
quite a significant performance gains so
for example here are
a couple of models for recognizing
images
that that we measured and you can see
that uh
if i'll look at the the the the let's
see the left bars
yeah these three left bars sorry the
bars on the right the three bars on the
right
represent both integrity and privacy so
the
model can't the gpu can't see the data
in the clear and the gpu can't lie about
the results
and you can see we're getting like
factors of 10 or factor 4 or factor of
4.6
performance improvements over running
things on the cpu
yeah this is a factor of 10 faster than
running the job
on the on the cpu so this actually gives
quite significant
performance improvements of course um
even with this
it's still slower than running things
natively with no privacy on the gpu
security always comes at a cost yeah
nothing you can do about that
but at least it's not as bad as running
uh natively on the cp
on the cpu you're still able to use a
gpu that's uh that's in the cloud okay
so
what i want you to take away from this
is if you do want to run your
jobs in an enclave in the cloud there's
still a way to use
gpus you know and gain and gain
performance improvements
over running everything inside of the
enclave yeah so that's kind of one of
what i wanted you to take away from this
so the system is called slalom you're
welcome to uh to look to look at it and
you know if you're interested in using
it
you know please let us know all right
the last thing i want to talk about i
guess i only have i want to stop at uh
at 45 so i only have eight minutes and
then um
we'll take uh we'll take questions i'm
really looking forward uh to your
questions
and since this will be a fun topic to
discuss okay so the last thing i want to
talk about
is basically how do we keep uh the
training how do we keep uh
trading data private yeah so here's the
problem
the problem is when we train a neural
net using
using uh collected data samples the data
samples can often be private
yeah so in fact what might happen is
that we train on neural nets and after
the neural net gets trained
the attacker might try to interact with
the neural net and extract
the training data from the neural net
think of um
like a neural net that's trained to
recognize certain
um i don't know certain uh hell uh you
know health conditions based on various
images
based on x-ray images that it's trained
on well
once the model is available and is sent
to all the hospitals
we want to make sure that an adversary
can't actually look at the model
and somehow extract the images on which
the model from which the model was
trained
yeah that's kind of the goal we want to
train a model but we want to make sure
that the underlying data set
actually remains private okay so
let me show you how that's done by the
way i should say these are really
quite beautiful slides and they were
made by my student florian tramer so he
deserves credit
for these beautiful beautiful animations
so traditionally the way we achieve
we achieve privacy for the underlying
training data yes we train a model and
we want to make sure
that it's impossible to extract the
training data from the model that we
just trained
the way we do that is using a wonderful
wonderful idea called differential
privacy
this dates back to 2006 is due to dwork
at all
and the idea behind differential privacy
is basically to add noise to the
training process
so that no single training data
training element would be extractable
from the model okay so
technically what differential privacy
means is if i train on the top three
images
versus if i train on the bottom of three
images you notice the only difference
between the top and the bottom
is that the left image in the images on
the left are different i guess in one
case
it's a cat in the other case it's a cat
wearing a mask
yeah the point is that those two models
basically look the same we get the same
result
up to some e to the epsilon value yeah
that's kind of the point so
whether if i change only one element in
my training data
the resulting model is going to be the
same that's kind of the requirement for
differential privacy
and so you should ask me what is this
epsilon and it turns out um
the smaller epsilon is the more privacy
we have
okay so the goal is to train models that
is to come up with training algorithms
that achieve the smallest possible
epsilon so the way that's done
typically is you might know that when
you train a model you use gradient
gradient descents
so i'm not going to explain how gradient
descent works but that's how the
model training works and the idea behind
private training
is to basically add noise at every
gradient descent
descent steps you can see these red
arrows basically kind of add noise
and the final model that we end up with
it turns out can actually be proven to
satisfy a certain differential privacy
guarantee
all right so that's kind of the idea uh
behind private training
and again the private different the
differential privacy guarantee means
that nobody's data influenced the final
model
all right by much so that means that you
cannot extract
an individual's data just from the
trained model
okay so that's what private private
training means the problem is
that private training actually affects
the accuracy of the resulting model yes
in particular if we train without
privacy it's really quite amazing when
you train a model to recognize images we
achieve incredible accuracy yeah this is
very close to 100
in terms of accuracy however the meaning
to do private training
by the way this accuracy this is all
thanks to uh deep learning
uh this is actually worth worth uh
saying that
kind of a deep learning era where we
build models that are that are many many
many layers
that's what enables us to achieve such
high such high
accuracy in the old days pre-2011
everybody was using shallow models very
very few layers
and as a result you can see the accuracy
back in
2010 was dramatically lower
so the interesting thing is that once
you train with privacy
even if you train a deep neural net it
turns out
that um there's a significant impact to
privacy you can see
to accuracy you see there's like a 40
drop
in inaccuracy as a result of uh of
private training
yeah so that's kind of based on uh sort
of you know the latest work on uh
uh private training so that's
interesting right so there's a trade-off
between
uh the level of privacy you want in the
accuracy of the model
what's interesting is because the drop
is so significant
it turns out if you go back to the old
days of how image recognition works
using basically pre-trained uh features
then you can actually just use very
simple uh very simple classifiers this
is the star here
that actually achieves privacy and
actually interestingly beats the deep
neural net methods yeah so let me
explain what happens here
so the idea is maybe in some sense i
should say i should say the reason that
private training
private gradient descent
has trouble the accuracy is is heard
somewhat
is that you have to touch the data many
many times one time one time for every
step in the uh gradual descent is a
grading descent and as a result you can
you have to kind of cut off the
algorithm before it converges to the
best possible result
whereas it turns out if you just use
handcrafted features so you don't use
learning to learn the features you just
use sort of standard
sift like features that were already
used you know um you know in the early
days of image recognition
and then you just train a simple linear
classifier using those features
it turns out you're already able to get
better results than what the deep neural
nets will give you yeah that's kind of
that's kind of surprising
that uh you know pre-cl
pre-chosen features uh using a linear
classifier
will actually perform better than a
neural net a deep neural net that's
supposed to learn the features on its
own
again without privacy the neural net
will beat this hands down
the minute you introduce privacy uh
somehow
learning the features you know exhausts
a lot of the privacy budgets
so kind of using pre-trained features
helps us
learn things more accurately okay so you
can see
that again if you this is basically
the ax asset access is the differential
privacy level so remember the smaller
epsilon is
the better so as we move to the right on
the x-axis
we get better differential privacy so
stronger differential privacy so
accuracy goes down
as a result but you can see the green
line uses handcrafted features and
simple linear models
whereas the red line uses deep neural
nets and deep neural nets and amazingly
the green line does better than the red
line yeah so simple
handcrafted features using linear models
can beat
the deep neural nets when uh when
privacy is
so required story actually gets even
more interesting in that
it turns out if the if you have enough
data
yet if you have enough data eventually
the deep neural nets
with privacy will actually beat the
handcrafted handcrafted features yeah so
you can see
this red line here corresponds to deep
learning and the green line
corresponds to handcrafted features
using linear classifiers simple linear
classifiers
and you can see that when you get to a
certain point on the right
with a huge number of samples the neural
nets actually do get better
so what it says is that private deep
learning eventually
gets really good but you have to have a
lot of data
in order to to get to that point so this
is kind of a bizarre
um conclusion to take away from this
where basically you know someone like
google who says we would say yes we need
to collect
much more data in order to improve user
privacy it's kind of a
it's kind of a contradiction that you
need more collect more data in order to
improve privacy
but it turns out that's actually uh how
how
deep neural nets with privacy uh would
work
however there's another approach there's
another approach which is to say
that we can use publicly trained
features yeah so basically
we can train on public data so no
secrecy
no privacy involved we train features on
the public data
and once we have we've trained those the
features on the public data that's when
we move to the private data
and use the features that we train this
is sometimes called transfer learning
where you learn features on one data set
and then you
use those features on another data set
and then we lose we use
the features that we just learned to
train a linear classifier
uh and that actually still remains
private and then it turns out actually
accuracy goes up
quite a bit yeah so you can see that now
there's only a five percent gap
between training with privacy and
training without privacy so the lesson
here
is when you train when you learn the
features
that you want to train on those are good
to do
on public data so you don't exhaust your
privacy budget on learning features
and then once you've used once you've
learned those features that's when you
apply them to your private data
and now you don't need to make as many
steps in the gradient descent process
and you quickly converge to um to a good
model
all right so that's kind of the lesson
here in fact that it is possible to
train
goods private models you just have to do
it differently
from how um you would train a
non-private model
all right so i think it's kind of an
important lesson and i hope that's uh
that's that comes across
okay so i think i'm going to stop here
the last thing i'll say
is this is really quite a fascinating
area there's a tremendous amount of work
on this topic there's lots and lots of
work happening
on adversarial machine learning if
you're interested in learning more
um we're part of a center it's an nsf
center on trustworthy machine learning
it's called ctml
i put up the website for the center here
there are a lot of publications
that you can look at to learn more about
this there's also a number of
systemization of knowledge papers socs
or survey papers
of the area so you can search around for
some um
survey papers of machine learning of
adversarial machine learning i kind of
put a reference to one
in euros p 2018 but there are many
others
and then there are also wonderful blog
posts on adversarial machine learning so
if you just
search for adversarial machine learning
you'll find really good blog posts that
sort of explain the problem
and some attempts at what can be done
about this so this is really
you know it's really quite an exciting
area it's really amazing
that um all this all this is happening
you know
both very clever attacks very clever
defenses
and sort of uh you know trying to kind
of
make machine learning as robust as
possible it's really
quite a an active and exciting area so i
encourage you to get into it
and learn a little bit more about it by
yourself all i wanted to do here
was give you sort of a high level
overview and kind of a taste of what's
happening in the space
all right so i'll stop here i think i'll
hand it over back to uh pax
uh dan we have a ton of questions that
came in
uh so you know across the kind of range
i just looking at them maybe you know
we'll jump through a couple of these
a couple of the topics so maybe the
first one is just can you talk a little
bit about you know we learned about the
attacks on machine learning
how is machine learning being used for
things like malware analysis oh yeah for
sure uh yeah so there's a bit
there have been a couple of attempts at
using using machine learning to identify
malware
um it turns out that that doesn't work
too well
yeah there are again this is an example
where
adversaries really do try to confuse the
machine learning algorithm
so it turns out if you look at um so
you can train you know you can take a
bunch of non-malware
pieces of software and malware pieces of
software you can label them malware not
malware and then have the machine
learning
model algorithm try to learn to
distinguish one from the other
so it does do it does produce something
uh but it turns out it's actually quite
easy to confuse it
yeah it turns out that the kind of
features that it's uh
homing in on are not exactly the right
features
that um you'd like to use and it turns
out it's much easier
actually maybe i can say one feature it
turns out that uh it turns out that
malware pdfs
tend to be longer than non-malware pdfs
yeah so it uses the length of the
document
to identify whether it's malware or not
so you can see how to confuse it
you just try to build malware that
happens to be short right and then it
wouldn't detect that as malware
um and so those are that that's a really
good question but it's an example where
again
adversaries will try to build
adversarial examples
that are malware but would be classified
as non-malware and as far as we can tell
that's usually not that difficult to do
so i would not recommend using
machine learning algorithm to uh to
identify malware or at least not purely
rely on it for that
so maybe related to that a lot of the
examples you gave
were around image classification have we
seen similar kinds of adversarial
attacks
in natural language processing and you
know what do those look like
yeah that's a really that's a really
cool question so there have been yeah
there have been
some works on that as well so i have
several examples against nlp
um effectively what happens is it's
exactly the same problem yeah you can
kind of change you can train a model
to uh to answer questions like you know
read an article
and then answer some questions about
that article
and then it turns out you can add a few
a few sentences to the article
or add a few words to the article and
then when you answer
when you ask it the same questions it
just gives you completely wrong results
i think a a nice example of that so
priscillian gave a nice example of that
where you can train a model to um answer
a question like
you you um you train them you give the
model as an example you give them
you give them autobiographical pages of
various people and then
those biographical pages pages typically
would um include information like when
that person was born
so you train the model to answer a
question like when was so and so born
yeah and so what the model learns is oh
i'm going to look for a date
in the documents that you gave me and if
i can find the dates that then i
answered that as
the result but then it turns out you can
confuse it by basically adding a few
more dates to the document
and now the model doesn't know which
date it's supposed to uh to actually
produce
yeah so again it's learning how to
answer when was this person born
by learning that it needs to look for a
date in the given document
and that's pretty easy to confuse but to
confuse it then by adding some more
um some more words to the to the uh to
the given document so
um it's it's kind of interesting to come
up with maybe it's a little the way you
would come up with adversarial examples
against nlp
they're different from what you would do
for images but it's
doable nonetheless it's exactly the same
the same idea
so it's a great question but this
translates to other domains
and then related that you know how how
hard is it
why can't we identify what the poison
data said you know the poisoned
example is so if you have a thousand
pictures of dogs
and then one flips the model to identify
all dogs as fish why
why isn't there what makes it difficult
to go back through and identify that
outline
maybe i'll answer that in the context of
adversarial examples so during
classification time
right so so suppose you want to
recognize road signs right
so you build a model to recognize stop
signs and now the adversary is going to
give you some sort of a
perturbed image of a stop sign and the
question is why can't you recognize that
this is a perturbed image
right it's a great question and then the
model just says oh this is this is an
attack image i'm not going to answer it
right it turns out that the actual
model that recognizes that this is a
perturbed image
can itself be attacked right so that i
can prevent
the model for rent from recognizes that
something is actually
uh an attack image and so just like i
can build
adversarial examples against the core
recognition model
i can build adversarial examples against
the you know the attack recognition
model and make it think that something
that's an attack
is actually not an attack yeah so it's a
great it's a great question it's a very
good
uh attempt at defending but in fact that
can also be bypassed not it's not too
hard
it's a very good question thanks and in
terms of you know defense
are there any agreed upon measurements
or methods to to measure resistance to
adversarial
attacks do we have any standards out
there yeah
oh to defend to measure resistance
that's a that's an excellent question
um yeah that actually is a good research
question i have to say i don't know of
any
any way to actually measure that um
mostly because attacks are sort of
binary right i mean either there are
attacks
or there aren't attacks um what maybe
what you're kind of asking is
you know how hard is it to come up with
adversarial examples or
um you know maybe what kind of
perturbations you're supposed to use to
come up with adversarial examples
those things are hard those are things
that are hard to kind of capture in
numbers
so i would say again that's a fantastic
question thank you for asking that
but i would say that's kind of a good
research question how do we classify how
do we quantify
robustness um that's something i would
have to think about so
it's a good research question thanks
so maybe moving a little bit we can come
back if we have time to some of the
machine learning but we did get a fair
number of questions kind of on more
broadly about cyber security you would
ask people to submit so one that comes
up a lot and i think is worth
addressing again is the question of
quantum computing so how will that
how will quantum computing affect
computer security going forward and
in particular will it impact what we're
seeing right now with machine learning
models and security privacy wow okay
yeah so it seems like
every every in every one of these talks
people are interested in hearing about
quantum computing that's great i mean
i'm happy happy to discuss that
um so you know so quantum computing is
something that's probably
going to revolutionize computer science
you know and and
i would say maybe our grandkids maybe
our great grandkids
would be learning to program in quantum
c rather than than c
um so computers are just more powerful
when when they can use quantum physics
instead of uh the classical computers
that we have today
as you know one of the applications for
quantum computers is to break
existing public key crypto systems like
signature algorithms key exchange
uh things like that um there are other
applications for quantum computers
like uh computational chemistry maybe we
can do chemistry instead of
doing in the la in the lab maybe we can
do it better on a quantum computer
um and so those have to be the ones that
drive the development of quantum
computers right
so those applications to chemistry for
example would drive the
development of those computers breaking
cryptography is not a reason to develop
a quantum computer
and that's really important to
understand because we already have
cryptographic systems
that are secure against quantum
computation yeah so
just to rattle off a couple of names
there are things like lattice-based
systems
that can replace both key exchange and
signature schemes
there are misogyny-based systems there
are code based systems there are hash
based systems
there are many new cryptographic schemes
that are secure even if the adversary
has a quantum computer
so what that means is you know if you
have if you're worried about bitcoin for
example bitcoin you know
is based on signatures and the signature
algorithm that bitcoin uses today
it's called ecdsa is vulnerable to a
quantum computing attack
so what will happen is if we see that in
30 years
someone is getting close to building a
quantum computer all that will happen is
a bitcoin will simply shift
to using a quantum resistance signature
scheme what's called post quantum
signatures
and there are many of those as you
probably know nist the national
institute of standards
is even going through a process of
standardizing post-quantum cryptography
both for key exchange and for digital
signatures and so we already know what
to use
so what will happen is as quantum
computers
become closer to reality will simply
shift
to using digital signatures in key
exchange that is secure
they are secure against quantum
computing and um
basically the crypto will continue to
work as it does today
so breaking crypto cannot be the reason
to develop a quantum computer there has
to be
other commercial motivations for it and
i really hope that
chemistry is enough of a reason because
the investments to develop a quantum
computer
is going to be enormous it's going to
take 30 years of sustained investment
to develop one and we have to we better
see a return on investment
in less than 30 years otherwise no
company will do it only governments can
afford
to um just to such a long-term sustained
investment
so i hope i hope it will happen but it
can't it can't be
um just just cryptography yeah
so and the timeline by the way is around
my guess is around 30 to 50 years
so hopefully that's when um that's when
when you know we'll shift to having
quantum computers all around us
perfect well dan thank you so much we're
we're at time
we have a lot more questions that came
in uh we'll share those with dan so you
can take a look and maybe there's
there's the seed of the next webinar in
there
so thank you again everyone who joined
us and thank you dan for
this wonderful talk yeah thank you all
this was fun hope to see you again in a
future talk
you